foreign check this out this is a map of
some of the battery manufacturing
facilities coming online in the US and
as you can see they're mostly over here
see as America tries to rapidly increase
its battery manufacturing capacity it's
creating what some are calling America's
battery belt but the decisions around
where to build these factories is moving
America's Automotive Heartland further
south redistributing thousands of jobs
in the process so what are the key
factors shaping where America's Battery
Bill is let's find out
okay so first we need to explore why so
many battery factories are being built
in America right now so
Saturday factories have been slowly
coming online in the US for years but
things stepped up again when Biden
signed the inflation reduction act which
requires a certain percentage of a
vehicle's battery be made in America for
it to qualify for federal incentives
spending on U.S battery factories
quadrupled between 2019 and 2022 with
some 70 billion dollars of Investments
for batteries and auto manufacturing
being announced over the last two years
and more than 15 new battery factories
or expansions have been announced since
the start of 2021.
so why are they mostly over here well
given that batteries are heavy things to
ship the obvious place to build battery
factories may seem to be right next to
an automotive plant as proximity can
reduce Transportation snarls that's
partly why some of the new factories are
in a similar area to existing Auto
factories but proximity Is far from the
only Factor deciding where these
factories should go as my colleague Nora
Eckhart has been finding out the center
of gravity for the automotive industry
has traditionally been in the midwest
around Michigan specifically and over
time that has shifted into the American
South and that's that's been expedited
with this EV building boom Nora has been
chatting to site selectors essentially
the people who decide where these
factories should go one key factor is
connectivity to transport networks like
Railways which are far more prevalent in
the east of America for a battery plan
or for an EV assembly plant access to
railway and ports is key that may
explain why these factories are in the
east of America but why they move South
so battery plants and EV assembly plants
require a lot of electricity and more
than your traditional gas engine plant
so the lower electricity costs in some
areas of the South compared to say
Michigan make that a lot more attractive
for automakers but perhaps the main
factor pushing these factories South is
whether the sites are TurnKey
essentially shovel ready sites with
connected utilities just waiting to be
developed on it's tough to build up the
facility itself and bring in the workers
but as long as you've got that base set
up it becomes really attractive for for
potential automakers Georgia says it
spent years prepping project sites to
attract car companies with its
commissioner for economic development
saying I feel like we are right now
riding that wave all of that has meant
that about two-thirds of the new auto
investment announced over the past two
years has gone down here to site from
the US South
so what does this mean for America's
Automotive Heartland of Michigan and the
Great Lakes I think a big question for a
lot of people in the industry is about
Michigan's future and if it's losing its
power in the automotive industry if
anything we're just seeing the industry
become a little more broadly dispersed
across the U.S instead of localized just
in the Michigan area but even with this
race to build factories the shift won't
happen overnight that's because as early
movers in U.S battery manufacturing have
found it can take years to train workers
and adapt Machinery to get a factory
fully operational so even though the
groundwork is being laid now it still
might take a few years for America's
battery belt to truly form
[Music]